bonjour à tous et merci nous fîmes
aujourd'hui on avait envie d'aborder
avec les mini de problèmes de boulimie
mais j'ai pas trop m elles ont fait
descendre l'abonné pour 3000 euros est à
ce prix là on peut avoir des
commentaires positifs et je le fais pour
une comédie français sur deux serait
qu'au début les gens finiront par
s'intéresser à nous alors aujourd'hui on
avait envie de partager avec vous sur
l'alimentaire parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile de passer au bio pattes
on est une famille nombreuse
[ __ ] mais merde vous vouliez pas qu'il
gamera l'un tout le monde s'en branle de
nous c'est chiant d'être allergique aux
chats [ __ ] on aura un chat des
millions de bulles
[Musique]